stripped off the new album Bush and a
very sexy beauty PR of course that the
by D Pharrell he co-wrote do you want
career old song he produced the whole
out for just the whole album yes Wow
now is it true that for L he was the one
encouraging you to be a bit more
family-friendly a bit more mainstream
with yeah yeah he made me change certain
words I had a song called so many holes
he made it so many pros well that
certainly toned it down on pros just
prostitutes no they're professionals oh
I see silly me ladies in the video still
look quite like hoes personal video and
then Pharrell is it true that II I mean
I'm sure you enjoyed working with you
but he did have some difficulties
working with you as well yeah when we
were working on a particular song called
California wrong um Stevie Wonder he
came up to the studio and for real he
called a secondhand contact from being
in the studio with me any kind of froze
he didn't know how to produce anymore he
was stuck it was like might have to
explain what the yes
so at Pharrell was in an environment
created by Snoop
Burrell was no longer the same Ferrell
he was now someone else he was not he
was not the greatest producer in the
world he was the greatest news he was
just the guy in the room
so with Stevie Wonder tried to talk to
him Stevie Wonder was in the mic boat
and you know Stevie can't see so Stevie
was waiting on some direction and
Pharrell was to give me no direction for
images and they're just
found a bumper sticker in the shape of a
pot plant that said [__] cops man right
here is where you got to do a little
tongue thing okay this is what it gets
interesting
it just smells